hi everybody thank you so much for
joining welcome to the r studio
enterprise community meetup i'm rachel
dempsey calling in from the our studio
office in boston today
we are streaming out to linkedin and
youtube live right now it's a huge thank
you to hannah who is hanging out and
helping behind the scenes too
if you've just joined now feel free to
introduce yourselves through the chat
window and
say hello maybe where you're calling in
from
we can see it coming in from
linkedin and youtube
but for today's meetup we are joined by
james wade research scientist at dow
chemical
now our studio we get the chance to talk
with so many people who are helping
others across their company improve
their data science skills
and one of those great people being
james wade with us here today
so i'm so excited to hear from james
today about the lessons learned through
teaching community building and
collaboration with
scientists and engineers across dao
just a few notes after and during james
presentation we will have lots of time
for q a as well
so you can put your questions into the
youtube chat
linkedin or use the slido link as well
for anonymous questions which we've
shown on the screen here
but for anybody who's joining for the
first time this is a friendly and open
meetup environment for teams to share
use cases teach lessons learned and just
meet each other and ask questions so
thank you all for making this a
welcoming community
i really want to create spaces where
everybody can participate and we can
hear from everyone
i really appreciate how kind and helpful
this community is and just like to
reiterate we love to hear from everyone
no matter your level of experience in
the field or the industry that you work
in
so always just a nice reminder for us
all to be nice in the chat too
but with that
thank you all again for joining us
i would love to introduce james and pull
him up on the stage here virtually as
well
so james is a research scientist working
in the chemicals manufacturing industry
as part of a research and development
team
james has a special interest in
sustainable materials design
to develop new capabilities for research
and talking with james it's clear he has
a passion for helping convince others to
give data science a try as well
so i'll pull you up over here james and
share your screen
great to have you here
thanks so much rachel and thank you for
giving me the opportunity to come here
today and share our experience with our
studio academy
we
have been focusing on upskilling what
we're calling citizen data scientists
certainly not a
a new term but one that we use readily
throughout our research and development
group and before i talk in detail about
our experience with our studio academy i
want to start by telling you a little
bit about who i am a little bit about
dao and a little bit about our research
and development group and how our studio
academy is a key role in upskilling our
researchers within this r d community
see if i can get my cursor over here
there we go
uh so i'm originally from south carolina
i have my journey through the
united states on the map here and i
continue to move further and further
north i'm now located in midland
michigan and if i go any further north
i'm going to have to get some
immigration documents
uh i'm a chemist by training i have a
phd in chemistry in particular
analytical chemistry where in my
undergraduate and graduate work i was
mostly focused on measuring biologically
related materials mostly
proteins with a focus on diagnostics but
now at dao i work on as rachel mentioned
characterization of materials i have a
particular interest in looking at
sustainable materials design and
development and also with the data
science focus have a strong interest in
high throughput research automation and
how we can use tools our tool belt of
statistics and ai and ml to advance our
material science innovation
so i mentioned that i'm here in midland
michigan this is where
dao is headquartered and i want to take
a few minutes to describe what dao is
focused on and how our research and
development group plays into that so
that you can get a better sense for the
types of people that were targeted
for this rstudio academy program
dao is a very large company though i
wouldn't be surprised if many of you
have never either heard of us or don't
know of the products that we develop and
that's because we're a
b2b or business business company
predominantly
many of our product development and in
turn our research efforts are aimed at
addressing many of the global mega
trends that i'm sure all of you are
familiar with these are things like
climate change
and a huge growth in the emerging middle
class a significant investment across
the globe in digital transformation and
trends related to urbanization
as a materials science company we're
focused on developing material science
innovation across areas touching
packaging infrastructure
consumer and mobility now i wish that i
had time to tell you about particulars
of our
innovation it really is what we get
excited about every day coming into work
but the overall key takeaway here is
that we're looking to apply science and
engineering expertise along with data
science tooling to innovate in this
material science arena
within r d in particular
we have a broad suite of capabilities we
have a few thousand researchers that are
working day in and day out towards that
innovation
and our capabilities span many things
that relate to data science in terms of
the amount of data that we're generating
we have robust high throughput and
analytical capabilities analytical in
this sense is what i
how i identify which is uh very getting
excited about making very careful
measurements of our most sophisticated
materials that we develop
we also have robust application testing
a significant in-silico modeling
capability and really what brings me
here today is a growing and significant
data science present to take advantage
of all of this enormous amount of data
that we're generating
i mentioned at the beginning of the talk
of we're using our studio academy to
enable citizen data scientists at dell
so what do we mean by that
well
us as researchers we come in to work
every day and either are generating
working with or both a set of messy
unstructured and scattered data
many of you i'm sure are used to working
with some messy data but some of the
particular challenges with the material
science and chemistry landscape is
representation of materials and polymers
molecules things of those natures
introduce some distinct challenges
related to data that make it even
messier uh than what
uh you might anticipate
from from a naive perspective
where we see a lot of value in
particular with data science is actually
taking this
significant amount of data that we
generate take a researcher that we
deeply embed into this data analysis
workflow and they can take their subject
matter expertise say a analytical
chemist like myself or maybe a synthetic
chemist who's an expert at making new
polymers and they can apply that
expertise in how they analyze their data
it's the combination of subject matter
expertise with those data science skills
where we see a significant amount of
value
now data science is a bit of a nebulous
term and you can sort of map onto the
definition what whatever you would like
but one useful representation that we've
we have internally
is this
example of a combination of domain
expertise
math and statistics along with computer
science now i imagine that many of you
have seen something similar to this in
the past
and in particular of how this applies to
research be the combination of domain
expertise and math and statistics this
would be the skill set that people
typically come into our research
environment with we we would call it our
traditional research
when we introduce additional software
and computer science expertise
we met with some math and statistics
that's going to fall under this machine
learning branch
a third piece that's often uh
underestimated in terms of the value and
significance for innovation is the
combination of our domain knowledge with
computer science skills that we we term
data stewardship
and it's at the intersection of all of
these of where we we find data science
now again we didn't come up with this
representation we're just borrowing it
from others
the key here is that we're not
necessarily looking to find a single
expert that can touch all of these areas
rather we're looking to build a
community of of innovators that
collectively can come and advance our
data science efforts leading to new
material science innovations
towards that end we have this citizen
data science program that aims on taking
this data collection wrangling and
analysis and trains translating that
into decisions or actions that we can
take
for
innovation and
ultimately wanting to make more money by
getting by selling new materials that
are addressing our customer needs
this
aim of the citizen data science effort
is to provide a governance framework for
best data practices
along with the behaviors to adhere to
those govern that governance framework
that are all data centric
when we pair the citizen data science
foundation along with a technology base
we have a significant significant
investment in our digital infrastructure
behavior and technology comes together
to form our data science or excuse me
our data foundation again with the aim
of getting to decision decision making
actionable insights to create new value
when we think of the goal of a citizen
data scientists within our research and
development group ultimately we're
aiming to construct a tidy data project
now in an r studio meetup i doubt i have
to define tidy data but the overall aim
here is to have a collaborative
transparent and reproducible workflow
each one of those descriptors is key
for
packaging our projects into
leverageable components that can further
their overall innovative pipeline
to
supplement this
citizen data science program we've
defined a series of guidelines that we
uh believe are critical towards a
success here
now i'm not going to go through all of
these that you see on the screen here
but they fall into four different
categories the first of which is data
organization these are things that i
imagine are familiar to many of you like
storing our data in tidy data tables
or stor and storing our data in a
managed system of record
we also want uh where we the the another
category here is the data analysis where
we want to separate out our data storage
in our analysis workflows and we also
want to uh create some transparency in
terms of how we analyze our data this is
looking at things like git based version
control to ensure that we have a good
reproducibility and reliability on these
methods
third is data access this is a
particular challenge for much of our
research where we're using often
proprietary data formats this is where
we want to make sure that we can store
data in a way that's going to be
accessible for the long term we can have
organized data but it needs to be both
organized and accessible in order for us
to have that durable value out of that
and then in particular looking for
long-term value pro
preservation we're
teaching
our citizen data scientists to package
their analyses so that they can be
leveraged by others who might not
understand all of the intricate details
of their project of of a particular
project but they can go and
still leverage those
key subject matter expertise expertise
that's encoded
in that package so that it can continue
to further innovation long past the
lifetime of the individual project
we have a significant program named
across all of these uh these guidelines
here they're easier said than done but
this is our ambition for where we where
we're aiming our citizen data science
program to head towards
of course
i i'd be remiss if i didn't mention
mentioned the tools that we use for this
there's a lot of different options that
you can go choose you'll probably not be
surprised by what we actually do choose
for for our environment but it's
critical that we have a workbench for
our citizen data scientists uh to to
work in
and here here are the criteria that we
look look at to evaluate the platforms
overall
number one is we want to make sure that
we have both an approachable and a
collaborative workspace that will
welcome new people that either are new
to the company or new to applying data
science to their research efforts
the second is that
we want to have a modern capable
environment that has extremely low
barriers to our exploring ideas so it
needs to be collaborative so that new
researchers can work with those who are
more knowledgeable in this data science
space
and we want to make sure that getting
started is something like a 10-minute
exercise where you don't have to go
learn an entire ecosystem in order to
start applying code-based data analysis
to gain additional insights from your
data
third
we want to make sure that our
we have a extremely safe and secure
environment that has
robust data connectivity so we're not
spending much of our time trying to get
access to the data instead we can focus
most of our time in analyzing that data
again ensuring that those connections
are made in a safe and secure manner
lastly this is a critical piece which is
making sure that you can actually deploy
your insights to other people
to get value out of the your data
science work
you have to be able to share that with
others and so a critical uh performance
metric for
our workbench is having these simple and
secure and of course rapid developments
as close to a single push button
deployment as possible
i said that you wouldn't be surprised uh
in our case we use our studio team and
take advantage of the workbench connect
and package manager
servers to collectively form this
rstudio team product for most of our
workbench efforts in dow now this isn't
our only tool that we use for data
science but it's certainly one that i'm
most excited about and we're able to
generate a lot of value from
okay so i've talked a little bit about
what we want to build focusing on that
tidy data project concept of being
collaborative and transparent i've
talked about where we're going to build
this work using the rstudio workbench or
team product
now the question is how do we build that
if you're like me
before our studio academy you
went and
did a simple google search
you'll find with these searching that
you have an immense amount of free
online resources that are available to
you to go learn pretty much any
programming language of interest
you could spend all of your time for the
rest of your life i think trying to
consume all of these uh
open available uh resources for for
learning programming
however what we found internally with
our citizen data scientists is that they
just didn't have the time outside of
work hours to go and learn something new
and add it to their role
so in particular our studio academy has
been a critical uh
metacritical need of empowering people
to work during business hours to go and
learn these capabilities
now
many of you might be uh unfamiliar with
rstudio academy overall so i want to
take just a few minutes to talk about
some of the
specif specifics of what academy is and
why it was so useful for our citizen
data scientists here at dell
you can go to the
linked address here and learn all about
the details probably in a more eloquent
and organized way than i'm going to
describe today but i want to talk about
the experience that we've had so far
as you might expect there's going to be
a series of lessons these are
interactive tutorials uh if you've
looked at the learn section learning
section of the rstudio website in the
past or looked at some of the learning
modules on our on the rstudio cloud uh
i'm guessing that you'll see something a
very similar experience with academy
what sets it apart is i think the sort
of the rest of the the components here
the project milestone is a challenge to
academy participants
where their
aim here is to recreate something like a
gg plot of a
linear regression for example
from this you you're taking the lessons
much like many other curriculum you
might see and you're applying it in
practice it's the practice piece that i
think is so critical to this
you will then bring everybody together
in group sessions where you can showcase
not only the milestone recreation but a
milestone extension to say you've taken
some core concepts and then can apply
them to go and see where else you can
take these capabilities
it's these milestone extensions where
i've learned a tremendous amount from
the other participants within rstudio
academy
i've been quite impressed even in the
first weeks of learning new things where
i thought that i already i had already
learned all that there was to know about
something like the uh our studio
development environment
these group sessions are
ways where not only you can show off
what you've done but you can also learn
from your peers and mentors
for our setup we had mentors both from
dao and from our studio
both of which were critical to ensure
success of the learners where we had the
programming expertise from and strong
familiarity with the content paired with
dao experts who could translate what the
students were learning week to week into
practical lessons uh for how they could
apply it to their own research
also with academy there's an opportunity
to meet with the the mentors in an
office hours type setting um these also
were critical to ask questions that
maybe people were a little bit too
hesitant to ask in a larger group
setting
and also a way to focus on getting
particular advice for their own research
projects that might not
apply to the larger group setting
and the final piece here is something
that
may sound obvious however the
daily practice of making this
continuous learning within the data
science realm uh a habit
i think that can't be overstated
it's something that has been critical
for me in my data science journey and i
think that it's one of the best ways
that we can ensure that through a little
bit of effort each and every day you can
see tangible benefits to create value uh
through uh
through projects that are outside of
academy overall
now i talked
there through a couple of the specifics
about what is included in academy
but i want to talk a little bit
broader about what
how to think about academy overall
i'm staring stealing this analogy from
from eric who i think is on the the
meeting with us today um where
we're not really talking about going to
an a training class where you're going
to be watching videos or listening to a
lecture series i emphasize that practice
component really what you're doing here
is
going and
learning a new skill much like you would
if you were practicing the piano
now you're not going to be playing at
advanced sonatas on day one but you
still can produce music you still can
produce value you still can produce
insights from that and it's that
continuous learning concept that i think
really is critical where you're
developing this habit as a as an
apprentice participating in this academy
program
okay so let's talk a little bit about
nuts and bolts
for academy
you you need a couple of things and now
these are our experience i i welcome uh
uh interruptions from eric or others if
anything i'm saying is no longer
accurate but
for us
you're when you're putting together a
cohort you need to have of course people
who want to learn
looking at something five to seven
participants within each of your cohorts
i was mentioning the mentors before you
need one mentor from our studio and then
another mentor
from your own organization
as i mentioned previously the key role
of the mentor from your organization is
to translate the learnings into the
systems that you already have in place
for your company for example
the third piece is you need a project to
work on
the closer the project is to your work
the better you're going to be spending a
significant amount of time uh working on
this project so it's worth the upfront
investment to make sure that it's one
that really makes sense for your
workflows
thinking about who could participate who
would be a good candidate
for academy
the number one
predictor of success in our experience
is intrinsic motivation
that might sound somewhat obvious but
you need to want to do this you you need
to
really care if you are learning the
content within academy
secondly
a good candidate will have a project
that they can go and apply the knowledge
that they're learning right away
ideally they could do it in parallel as
they're learning the the key concepts
within academy
and third you need to have both the time
and support
in order to participate
practically you probably want to make
sure that your uh your manager your boss
whomever
supports this program and wants to make
sure that you can dedicate time at work
during work working hours to invest in
upskilling yourself through the academy
curriculum
all right right so on the flip side of
that who might be a bad candidate who
probably should not participate in
academy now there's
lots of examples that i could think of
here
but i wanted to highlight a couple that
you might not think about
number one
you're an experienced r user
we
had a number of people say that they
they knew r but what they were looking
for was wanting to do it the right way
i can say that
from experience here that probably means
that you either are too knowledgeable uh
to participate compared to the other
members of your cohort
or you don't really have enough of that
intrinsic motivation
you're not necessarily learning a
particular set of the right way to do
things rather than learning maybe some
best practices that you can apply with
your peers
also thinking of this experience here if
you've already regularly are building
and deploying shiny apps probably too
advanced
if you're a regular contributor to tidy
tuesday on twitter again probably too
advanced
maybe the number one giveaway if you are
able to successfully achieve
writing some new tidy evaluation code
and you don't have to go uh look on the
rstudio community or go through the docs
yeah you're definitely too advanced
for academy
the other category that to look out for
here is people who are excited about
learning how to code but they're just
thinking of it as a new skill
we had a survey that we sent out uh
before our initial cohorts with academy
uh to get some
some sense of the community of why they
wanted to participate
we had a number of different answers
along the lines of yeah i think this
would be great for for a skill to add to
to my
uh my list
you probably don't want to select those
people for for our studio academy
predominantly because they don't have
enough of that intrinsic motivation to
want to go and complete the the
complete the curriculum and then apply
it to their work the other thing to look
out for is if you don't have a project
to apply it to it's likely that the
skills that you learn if you don't
maintain that habit if you're not
developing this as a continuous practice
you're probably not going to have that
good of an experience
okay enough of the negatives uh what
makes a good cohort
i mentioned that a cohort needs to have
somewhere between five and seven people
in it
and
dao is a very large company we have
around 36 000 employees i mentioned a
few thousand within our r d groups
spread across the globe
this made uh picking our cohorts a a bit
of a challenge what we've learned from
this we've had several now
is the components that make a good
cohort are
number one the people are from a similar
work group
it doesn't have to literally be the same
thing that people have the the identical
roles in fact we've found some good
uh outcomes from having people at maybe
some of our highest level of technical
leadership roles and some some people at
the various the earliest entrants into
the company those seem to work okay
together
what is more important is that the types
of problems that they're thinking about
on a daily basis are similar enough that
they can discuss with how they could
apply the new skills that they're
learning
to their own work
now again a nuts and bolts component
here is you want to make sure that you
have a similar time zone you don't want
people struggling to attend the the
group sessions those are critical to
success as we've heard from our
participants
and then the third piece here something
that we sort of learned the hard way of
making sure that everybody within a
given cohort is of a similar skill level
i had that long list of
identifiers that might suggest that
somebody is too skilled for academy
you want to make sure that if you do
have somebody with advanced skills
participating that they're well matched
with people who are at least close to
their skill level you probably don't
want a brand new beginner with somebody
who's regularly deploying shiny apps for
example
okay so let's talk about what uh people
thought of this
we surveyed our first cohort where we
had about 19 people participate to see
what their experience was like
i have two quotes that i pulled out from
the survey here
the first one is uh talking about the
fantastic user experience they had
really enjoying the bite-size learning
messages that that they got from the
lessons themselves and the second one
which was particularly encouraging to us
was was hearing how highly they
recommended this program for other
researchers within our company to go and
apply to their own work as well
this also gives some hopefully helpful
markers in terms of the time commitment
that you you should expect
the guidance that we gave in advance was
to spend uh about 30 minutes a day
on on the curriculum
including the uh not including the group
sessions so maybe adding an additional
hour to that
you can see from the learners that we
surveyed that most people were spending
between three and ten hours per week on
the on on academy
a few learners were spending more than
10 hours and a few
maybe were a bit too advanced spending
less than three hours per week on the
content
we also surveyed them about whether they
thought it was a good use of their time
if they recommended it to others if we
should invest more money into this and
the criticality of the mentors to this
now these might be a little bit
difficult to read but pretty much
everybody said that it was they either
agreed and strongly agreed with a few
being neutral
but overall what we saw was quite
positive feedback maybe the most
important metric from this was are they
still using with the content that
they've learned
surveying them six months after they
left academy we found that 16 out of the
17 of the survey respondents
were still writing code at least once
per month or more frequently
the one person out of the 17 who isn't
let me know that she took a new role
that was as more or less a data science
manager and so she wasn't writing code
on a regular basis but was still
applying what she learned every single
day and in fact more so than when she
first started the program
we were blown away by this feedback and
it really encouraged us as we started to
shape out future cohorts
i will admit that we probably had some
a bias in the amount of enthusiasm of
our initial participants so i don't
think we'll have quite the same level of
positive feedback as we survey future
cohorts but i do anticipate that we're
going to see continue to see really
positive outcomes from people from our
participants and academy overall
one point that uh we're still working on
today
is what do we do with people
after they graduate from academy
academy at least for our curriculum it's
might it will be different for yours for
sure
but we didn't focus too much on
reproducibility and deployment
but sharing your analyses as i mentioned
for the criterion for our workbench the
ability to share share what you're
creating share your insights that's
really where all the value resides
so looking at
some future developments for our own
internal efforts after academy
we are wanting to find ways to offer
more advanced lessons
i will give a bit of a challenge here
which is
creating some
of the more advanced lessons
is a bit of a challenge in that we don't
we can't look to our studio for as much
help here because most of the specifics
are actually something that is related
to us as a company not necessarily to a
generic data science concept
we also have a focus on transferring
people from the academy environment onto
our local workbench where they can go
and apply that to
our most sensitive of our internal data
there certainly was some work
going on
alongside uh the the participation in
academy where people were using our on
our on-premises capabilities
but smoothing that transition is
something that we could work on in the
future and then the last piece is
focused on community building
now that we have more and more people
that are able to participate in academy
we want to have a landing zone for them
to come and continue to learn from
others we have heard a number of times
that people miss academy they wish that
it could have gone on longer
and that community building is a
critical piece to ensure that people are
have that same positive spirit that they
can apply their data science skills
continuously
i want to close here by telling a little
bit of a story that came out of academy
which is one of our success stories of
what an academy participant was able to
create
with a little bit of additional effort
she got particularly excited about the
capabilities that she was building
but but this is a an academy graduate
who did not have prior experience
with our
prior to
this experience and what they were able
to go and create
this requires a little bit of
understanding of the sort of work that
went in that that this was
intending to address so in particular
the the the need here was that there was
a
piece of equipment that was
used for and analyzing some of our
products particularly its polymer
analysis tool
where users could come up and use this
instrumentation and collect their own
data
a benefit of this is that they don't
have to rely on subject matter experts
to go collect this but there was a gap
in that people were unable to go
and analyze their data without advanced
training
as a solution to this a shiny app was
built that allowed the user to come and
amp to analyze
using enough subject matter expertise
that was not
encoded in one-on-one mentoring instead
it was encoded in the
it was encoded in code
where you could go and apply that code
to analyze the data and extract those
valuable insights
the app itself had a number of different
components such as selecting and
plotting analyzing that data
automatic report generation uh viewing
of historical data and then an ability
to go and inspect calibration uh
curves to ensure that the the results
were in fact of value
now
i will say that
this was not solely the academy
participants
effort in contributing to this but she
is a very valuable and active
contributor to this capability and is
currently uh becoming the predominant
maintainer of this code base
so academy
empowered her to be able to continue to
learn tackle new code tackle new
packages and be able to apply that to to
a
tool that is
creating an improved employee experience
for for both the developers of the tool
themselves they don't have to spend as
much time coaching people on data
analysis and also for the end users of
the shiny app where they can have a a
much streamlined approach and are no
longer reliant on others to extracting
insights from their data
the last thing i want to say here is a
huge acknowledgement to many of the
people that that made this uh successful
academy
partnership possible i want to give a
particular shout out to tony sokolov i
saw him in the chat here so i know that
he's watching along with me
a huge thanks to the both dao and r
studio mentors for all the work that
they put in uh to make this program a
success um and i want to thank all of
you for
giving me the opportunity to speak about
this today and i'd be very happy to take
any questions that people have
about our own academy experience or
about the questions you might have for
your own
so thank you very much
thank you so much james
that was great we're all clapping even
though you can't hear us right now
i i see there's a quite a few questions
coming in right now
so let me organize myself here
um but just a reminder to everybody that
you can ask questions on youtube live if
you're watching there or on linkedin if
you're watching there and if you want to
ask questions anonymously you can do so
as well i just put the
the link there on the screen
but i see
um laura asked a great question over on
slido
and it was
um would be fun to learn
how do you handle those that no coding
would be useful to them but can't
motivate to take five steps back to take
10 steps forward
yeah that's probably our toughest use
case but
typically what we'll do in that case
because we have a somewhat large base of
researchers we typically will pair them
with somebody who might have that
capability
where you could accelerate their
individual project work so you pair
somebody somebody like an rstudio
academy graduate and
have them work side by side on
potentially going and doing the actual
project itself
but if it's the the situation where they
predominantly want to
learn these capabilities themselves if
it's somebody who really just wants to
learn that
but doesn't have a use case right away
our recommendation in that case is to
have them go and take advantage of the
free online resources that that all of
us i'm sure are familiar with so i i
think in that the
it's probably an unsatisfactory answer i
know that i would probably be
unsatisfied if i got that from my survey
response that i filled out but it's it's
really a question of the uh that again
that intrinsic intrinsic motivation if
they're not excited to learn the content
um we we think that there might be other
opportunities for them to go and learn
that instead
i guess one one thing i will add as well
is um
if it's a time issue
we
did spend a good bit of uh of effort to
to convince leadership of our internal
leadership of the value of these sorts
of skill sets so having a base of
projects that have already created value
from this is a really good
argument i think for
dedicating the time
awesome i'll try and be better about
showing these on the screen right away
here we go penny asked the question how
can more advanced users participate in
developing curriculums
yeah that's a great question
what we have done um is we
a group of us it was predominantly tony
i should say uh was heavily involved in
the developing the curriculum uh for our
learners and so it was a curriculum that
was based off a real data set that was
sanitized and anonymized in a way that
would allow us to release it externally
so what i would look for for the more
advanced users is to identify use cases
where you have a good data set that
might be representative of what other
people could see
i
also would encourage anybody who has the
skill set is already familiar with a
shiny app development to go and try to
create some modules of yourself
the caveat i would give there is that
there has been tremendous thought into
developing the academy curriculum over
don't
let your leadership convince they
convince you that you don't need this
that you can just do it yourself uh it's
fantastic curriculum uh and i would
encourage you to try to take advantage
of that rather rather than try to roll
your own for the more advanced content
um maybe take advantage of some
publishing capabilities like uh maybe a
marked our markdown based website or
maybe a quarto based website if you have
some early adopters out there
where you can go and create some
interactive or at least some some
simple websites that that you could
publish for others to go and take
advantage of
great thank you
another question over from youtube is
does academy also teach good coding
style and version control
the
absolute curriculum like the particular
curriculum that you'll see will be based
off of your own um desires so if you
have a strong desire to include git
based version control that is certainly
something that can happen
it was not covered in ours in favor of
other topics there's a lot to cover
in 12 weeks we wish we had more
the coding style will come out of all of
the tutorials or written and following
i assume the tidy verse style guide
that's just how i learned so it's i
don't know anything else from that but
you can if it you can select amongst the
list of topics whatever is important for
the participants in the individual
session thank you
someone had asked on slido anonymously
if you're trying to sell academy to the
individual who would fill the group
mentor role what level of commitment and
bandwidth do they need to have
so uh i'm actively trying to sell that
role as we're shaping future cohorts
the
[Music]
most significant piece there is a
the skill set that you need to have is a
familiarity with how data science is
done at your organization
you don't have to for example be an
expert in r
we have some experts in python who have
already participated as mentors and in
terms of effort you need to have i would
say about three hours a week that you
could dedicate
the first hour would be attending the
group sessions the second hour would be
it would be attending the an open office
hours period which
is somewhat optional but i would
encourage a mentor to attend and the
third is being able to answer questions
sort of as an ad hoc basis now i would
say that three hours a week is probably
the floor i would
want i would
encourage a mentor to dedicate at least
a half a day if not more and what likely
will come out of this is some projects
works where you can work one-on-one uh
with some of the participants to
translate what they're learning and
you'll you'll see opportunities where
you could streamline some of their code
where if they haven't really gotten deep
into dplyr yet and you can see a way to
have a streamlined pipeline that's
something that would take a little bit
more effort but i i think would be worth
it to accelerate some of the learning
thank you thanks for letting us through
all these questions at youtube james
um
there's a lot of great ones coming in
someone just asked is the type of data
you work with relevant to the work you
do at dao or is it random data sets
regardless of which company you're with
for our use case it was literally data
from a project it was not a successful
project but it was a real project so it
was as real as we can get in in terms of
the data we did simplify it a small bit
for uh to not
intimidate people too much uh from some
of the the volume or maybe the messiness
of the data
but it's as real as we could get and
still
let sort of
people outside of the company see it as
well
it's awesome
so somebody else asks what other ways of
teaching are have you tried or
considered at dao and how does academy
compare
i can speak from my own experience and
what is not the right way to do it
i try to organize a
local section amongst my technology area
of having meetings every couple of weeks
where we would cover maybe a chapter or
two
of r for data science i imagine a book
that many of you familiar with
what i found was that people were able
to
quite easily
answer the
or
complete the challenges throughout those
chapters what was missing there was the
actual community building and the
practice so people were able to hear me
talk about why i got so excited about
the capabilities but
not as much about
how they could go and translate that to
their own work it was more they were
understanding what the tools that i were
building
rather than
doing it in practice
the other aspects that we've looked into
are some of the open
for getting the name of it but the
online courses that you could go and
take i myself learned from corsair of
course but uh that was
um i don't know
six years no not quite five years ago i
think at this point
i really enjoyed that but you'll see
that there's a significant pool of
people
who got to get so excited about the
programming that they're self they're
enough of self-learners that they can go
and do that so
that's it
it's sort of maybe an unsatisfactory
answer there but we found that people
who can learn this stuff on their own
and for the most part already have and
that's where academy fits in is
addressing the people who want to learn
it but have not been able to find the
the bandwidth to go and and learn it on
their own
great thank you
there's another question coming over
from youtube and it is what is the
duration for the training in our studio
academy
so for ours it's 10 weeks of content
there is a break week built in
it was impossible for us and i think for
everybody to find a continuous set of
weeks where nobody's going to go on
vacation so you have a catch-up week and
then there was also a week where
we had somebody from our studio come in
and share some of the capabilities of
the rstudio connect product uh this is
something that i mentioned that at the
beginning of the talk that we already
have internally and it was a kind of a
demo of the capabilities of that
uh where we uh we actually put uh some
uh additional content to to take people
from seeing it presented from the art
studio perspective to how you would
actually do that internally it's not
much different but just kind of like hey
here's here's the account that we need
to create for you here's the server
location here's how you could go do this
right after you you hear from our studio
and how to go go deploy a shiny app for
example
great i'll let you take a sip of water
there too before i throw some more
questions
but um if anybody is interested in
learning more about academy i put the
link on the screen too and you can
always book a time to chat with our team
about it there too i i love to see all
the comments in the chat as well coming
through and people who are interested in
it
um let's see
one is can you have multiple groups go
through at the same time or just one
cohort and what if we wanted to upskill
hundreds of people
we have had
three cohorts and four cohorts go at the
same time
and we are currently wondering how we
can go and scale it i will say that the
limitation on scaling it to hundreds of
people is more on us
we want to make sure that we have just
as good of a user experience for the
academy participants
as the
19 people who did it the first time as
if we had 100 people or 200 people do it
at the same time i i'm
questioning if we have the bandwidth
internally to make sure that we're
giving everybody that the attention that
they would need
in particular here is capturing them
from they see something that they want
to they want to go do and then go
actually do it in practice i when
the you know you're naturally going to
feel
frustrated and get very used to seeing
errors in the r console whenever you're
learning a new programming language but
we
don't want that to be coupled by
frustrations and how we actually go do
that do that in something like okay
here's a data source that i want to go
connect to here's a transactional
database
that sort of work is something that you
would need
dedicated additional mentors outside of
the academy mentors to make sure that
people are able to go and do that work
so we've started somewhat slow
intentionally to make sure that we get
this right we found that there's a broad
level of upskilling to that i was
talking about the citizen data science
capabilities uh maybe a baseline level
of
data science competency that can that
can be scalable that can go to hundreds
of people the in-depth training going
into writing code day in and day out
that's something that at least for us
we've started out going slowly and we're
as i mentioned looking at how we could
go and scale that to many more people
great thank you a question that i had um
is how did
like how did you find out who might be
interested and get the word out to
everybody
we initially
as part of this citizen data science
program we also have a large program
related to upgrading our digital
infrastructure
so we had a series of focal points and
internal focal points that
we contacted to see who they thought
would be good candidates
those candidates were asked to fill out
a survey we ask them questions like how
interested are you in learning are on a
five-star scale
what projects
would you like to apply this to
where
would you go and
or excuse me what have you learned in
the past what pro programming language
do you have
what
is your level of are already i will say
that even the people that i know for a
fact are quite advanced are
practitioners would not call themselves
advanced in the survey so whatever
people say i sort of bump it up one so
if somebody says they're a beginner i
kind of slot them in as intermediate but
those are the sorts of questions that we
asked via the survey we then got
together to select the indiv the cohorts
and that's where the advice came from of
how to how to shape these
the the cohorts in the end
and it's we're still learning exactly
what a what an ideal cohort looks like
again fortunately because we have such a
large base of people that we could be
pulling from
we can the
well i guess maybe not fortunately the
possibilities there may be endless to
some extent
uh and the only thing that that i would
definitely say to to avoid for cohort
shaping is having that huge imbalance
and skill set
thanks james uh let's see there's a few
other questions on slido right now and
um
one says
this seems like a good way to set your
company apart from others
advertising that you help learning
learners upskill in coding are you
hiring
uh we definitely are hiring i am not
very involved in that but i can i see
that tony has been answering some
questions here so tony might be able to
go and grab some links related to that
we are particularly interested in people
who have that scientific expertise that
they want to combine with data science
and it's a
we are all way busier than we would like
to be so we would love
uh to hire lots of people to come help
us do this work the number of projects
that we have is uh enormous and uh we're
growing the number of people that we
have to work on them but i don't know
that we can grow fast enough to meet the
demand for all the great insights and
value that have come out from this so
it's i love working on this i love the
tooling
that we've been able to work on and it's
it it really is exciting and satisfying
to take these intuitions that we have
about our data and translate that into a
real reproducible analysis
thanks james
one other question i see over here is
after our studio academy's 10-week
training is academy still available for
questions support or consult
yeah so the academy content is up for at
least three months um i don't know how
long it actually is but it's it's it's
the content itself is still available
i don't know if if we have any promises
about the mentors to hang around
but i will tell you that they've still
been answering questions uh so we have
uh we added them to we use teams as our
internal messaging service
and i still see them popping up
what has helped with this is this longer
term ongoing relationship with our
studio where we feel perfectly
comfortable bothering
some folks of with with questions when
we have them leveraging support
as as well for some of these
capabilities so i don't know
what is available to everybody but i
know that we have not struggled to get
answers to questions when people have
them i will say that i mentioned that
community building piece
we're
one part that we've struggled with is
actually getting people away from just
the academy community to the larger data
science community and we're trying
one
action we've taken for that is having
bi-weekly office hours where anybody it
doesn't have to be an academy
participant but anybody can show up with
questions cool stuff they want to show
off talk about anything that's happening
within the our python communities uh so
that's really uh been it's it's growing
uh slowly but it is growing that that's
a that's a piece of where i would
recommend rather than relying on
the the our studio folks for for
questions is to focus predominantly on
the community building
great thank you
i see somebody asked a question earlier
on youtube is academy only for r
right now the answer to that is yes
i will say that i know that it is very
actively being worked on um for a
python-based curriculum
i i won't say timings to not stress eric
out um but i know that i know that that
should be coming soon
ish i know eric's hanging out behind the
scenes so just put your video on if you
want me to pull you on stage too
um and another question was how can a
data science student
participate in our studio academy
and i know i was just looking at a
virtual course that's being offered by
the academy team too so i can go and
grab that but not sure if you know
any other streams
that i don't um i think if you're the
community that i've
uh participated or maybe even more of a
lurker in uh for learning
mostly visualization is the tidy tuesday
but i don't know of a larger outside of
this
effort
i just sorry i was trying to chat with
eric behind scenes but i um did just put
the
the link to that workshop in the chat
window too um hannah if you want to copy
it over to linkedin i don't think it
copies over from this platform
um let's see
someone had asked
um so
so far you've mentioned data sharing
with endow do you or how do you
collaborate with others outside of dao
yeah that's a great question
we are so working in the chemicals
manufacturing industry the material
science industry
by its nature it's been a
risk-averse industry not necessarily
within
r d but overall when we work with either
suppliers or customers there's sometimes
some hesitancy and wanting to openly
work and share data
where we've seen some
[Music]
cracks i think in opening up these these
collaborative floodgates and they're
definitely not open yet
but where we've seen some cracks there
is is where we can jointly go and
capture value together so this is not a
project i
i
worked in a rotational program so i'm a
chemist but i did spend about six months
in a supply chain organization or our
supply chain organization where we were
able to
look with
work with our both suppliers and
customers to go and jointly
reclaim some
trade duties that we haven't having to
pay
that was a easier phone call to make of
saying hey if you work with us we can go
jointly get a couple hundred thousand
dollars maybe a couple million dollars
um that is sort of the beginning of
these efforts it was leveraged with a
data science foundation of how to go
build that um most of our collaborations
are going to be with
academics at various universities or
maybe national labs
that is that's most of what our collab
is doing we have lots and lots of of
interns that are that are here right now
both at the undergraduate and graduate
level
but we that's something we would like to
see
i would like to see us grow in the
future is having more contributions to
open source tools
being more open with our our tooling
it'll be a while before we're too open
about maybe some of our uh secret sauce
related to
some of the more chemical foundations
but the tooling i think is something
that we could uh convince leadership of
the value and establishing the the our
data science bonafides for example
thank you james i think we're getting
down towards the end of the questions i
do see one other one on slido that was
how does our studio the r studio academy
coach handle access to company's
sensitive data is there proper
authorization process in place within
academy
i can't remember the actual agreement
that we had i like to avoid those sorts
of things as much as i can and just
focus on the fun part but most of the
actual sensitive data we that's the role
of the
um the your for us it's the dow mentor
of your organization's mentor
so we did go through our
our own internal release process for
sharing our data an anonymized version
of our data but that
might not be something that you that you
would have to go through
it's really going to be up to the
comfort of your organization
we
i don't think we went through
ndas or anything like that uh to set
this up and it's easier to have to avoid
going through these things i don't know
about the willingness to sign those
sorts of things um within our studio but
it for us we haven't had the need for
that i guess that this actually is a
good
maybe teaching moment to where
this would also apply to getting help
from the community anytime you want to
ask a data science related question it's
great if you can create that
reproducible example that you could go
and showcase so that others could learn
from you as well so if you can translate
your challenge into a reproducible
example then there shouldn't be any
issues with with the sensitivities
great thank you i see eric's face over
here backstage i'll i'll pull you on as
well and eric pate is our vp of
education products here at our studio as
well
can you hear us eric are you muted
oh
well i just wanted to add maybe in case
not everybody saw that in in the comment
but
there is a link to
a hybrid workshop at conf so in case you
know you're in an organization where you
don't have seven learners and you'd like
to get a taste of academy there is a
slightly modified version of academy
that's going to be held
three weeks before conf two days at conf
and then three to five weeks after conf
um which so
maybe we can put the link again
somewhere but i i i saw that yes
people unfortunately can't click on that
link there so i'm gonna re-share it
or hannah if you want to reshare it in
the chat as well that would be great
there we go
awesome
i can also mention that tony and i will
both be at our studio conf so if you
would be there and you want to talk more
about some of the stuff we'd be happy to
yeah i'd be curious to hear in the chat
who else we'll be at
at our studio conference as well i know
there'll be lots lots of birds of a
feather groups and
um different opportunities for us all to
meet so excited to see you all there too
uh let's see if you one other question i
know you mentioned
that a lot of people are still using are
now after academy but do you have any
statistics on
exactly how many
of the first cohort we do it was nearly
all of them so at the worst it was 16
out of 19.
and i think the other two who didn't
fill out the survey even though i nagged
them
uh they
i think they're still using it as well
so conservatively i would say 16 out of
19. we haven't actually surveyed the
most recent crop of students so we're up
to about 50 participants total
we haven't surveyed them yet we want to
give them they're a little bit too close
to their time that i we might be biasing
our statistics a bit
so we'll be looking at that that's
something we want to monitor as a
overall success metric but i would say
that if
you kind of want to aim for
the um
maybe at least 50 of the people that are
still doing that one unintended value
that we've got from this is i've
actually had much better collaborations
with people who've participated in
academy and aren't necessarily going to
be doing the coding themselves but now
can converse with me in a much more
efficient manner about the types of
challenges that we want to go and
address i don't know that that should be
or shouldn't be the majority of
participants but having people in
leadership or managerial roles we've had
some success with that again it's the
minority of participants but they have
very positive feedback to share and i've
seen some positive impacts from them
participating in it as well
that's great thank you so much i think
we got through all the went through all
the questions so thank you all for all
the awesome questions as well
um i'll double check to make sure that
there aren't any others on slido
but also just wanted to put on the
screen again if anybody is interested in
learning more about our studio academy
but just want to say thank you so much
james for for sharing your experience
um and eric if you want to add anything
in here as well i'll give you the mic as
well
well i i want to echo your thank you to
uh to james and to tony who's i know you
know has not been vocal other than the
chat but has been instrumental as well
um
you know the experience with dao
represents kind of the the the best we
see out there
because we have james antony and a few
others who are heavily involved
and as i always say you know we can make
academy as efficient for learning and as
good and tailored and so on but in the
end the key
is a partnership we've got
with our customers like dao
and and working together and uh
yeah i think you know
james and tony have done
everything perfect by the book like
and we are learning from it and
you know we use
a number of those examples with other
customers on you know what's good to do
and
what's good to avoid as well so uh thank
you so much again
that's amazing thank you and yes thank
you tony as well i appreciate you
helping in the chat too to answer some
of the questions
um i just wanted to pull your screen up
here again james if people wanted to get
in touch or had any other follow-up
questions too
lots of ways to get in contact so
yeah
absolutely but thank you all again so
much for joining um i did just also want
to put on the screen if you're
interested in joining future events
um
we do have a whole calendar of meetup
events and data science hangouts that
happen every thursday at 12 eastern time
with different data science leaders from
the community so i love to see you all
there too
but thank you all so much for joining us
today and
huge thank you to you james really
appreciate it and have a great rest of
the day everybody
bye everybody
bye everybody